hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown uh my name
is always is alex mullering and i'm
excited to be your instructor tonight uh
and we're actually gonna be working on
something kind of different so i've been
a little hesitant to begin end games
with this class
mostly because it's the area of the game
that i'm the least familiar with it
requires a lot of precise calculation
and a lot of you know study and
knowledge but at the same time it's also
an important part for most chess games
so we got to tackle it at some point
so tonight we're going to be looking at
the beginning of the end game
what are end games how do we survive
them and how can we push forward and win
so
the first thing i want to kind of talk
about is this idea with end games of
known positions
one of the struggles a lot of people
have with endgames myself included is
one wrong move
could completely lose you the game you
know if you're playing an opening or a
middle game and you make kind of a weird
move or something a little off
usually it won't be that impactful until
you get to higher and higher levels but
one wrong move in the end game could be
the difference between winning and
losing
so with a known position
we're gonna try and uh eliminate some of
the amount of calculation we have to do
and by that i can say if i'm looking at
this position
uh it doesn't matter white or black to
move i already know that white is
winning this game
uh with best play
and because of that if i can
go into a puzzle or i'm playing in a
game and see that i can get into this
type of position
then i don't have to calculate because
once i know i can reach this position i
already know how to win
so what we're going to be working on is
one what are these positions that we can
get to how do we know we're going to win
and then what's the technique used to
actually win these
so in this particular position
it doesn't matter if it's white or black
to move but it is white to win
let's start and say that it is white's
turn to move so
with white to move does anyone either
online or in the audience have any
suggestions how should white try and win
this game what would you play
any ideas how should white make progress
here
yeah king to e6 i like this move a lot
we're gonna take opposition so
opposition is any time that our king is
directly uh one square away from our
opponent's king that's this little blue
circle here that i've used to represent
that
and you notice that because we're in
opposition our king is also controlling
all three squares in front of the king
and we're actually preparing
to move in so whichever way black moves
uh black is lost if black moves to d8
we will go to uh f7
and if black moves to f8 we will go to
d7 so for instance if king two d8
we moved to f7 and we've made what i
call the red carpet
and if you see here all of the squares
that our pawn has yet to move on the way
to promotion are covered
and so there's just nothing black can do
to stop us from promoting this pawn it
doesn't matter what moves are played
because all of these squares are
defended the pawn is just going to
promote
and with a king and queen um if you
don't know how to win this is a great
thing to study but we won't be looking
at that tonight
but with a king and a queen you should
be able to win this game quite easily
now let's imagine that in this position
it's actually uh black to move
so i'm going to kind of
shuffle the pieces around a little bit
and we've returned to this position it's
black to move and black is thinking okay
well you just
took opposition and forced me out so now
it's my turn i'm going to take
opposition
what can white do to still win this game
i'll show one option that doesn't work
here
if we try and uh avoid this king by
going king to e6 now
with the idea that we want to defend
this square where the pawn is going to
promote
so we want to move to f7 this doesn't
work
because their king will then take
opposition again and we can shuffle the
pieces around for a while but this isn't
going to get us anywhere right black can
keep
bodyguarding
this
square so we need to do something else
what else can we do here
move backwards one square
so we could move back um
the issue here is one
very important thing to remember with
all king and pawn end games is you
always want to keep your king in front
of the pawn
because now it gets even worse this is
actually now a draw black will bring
their king forward
take opposition again
and black is cutting off all squares for
our king to move forward so no matter
what we do now this is actually going to
be a draw by force and we'll take a look
at that uh shortly the best move in this
position is actually just to move the
pawn
normally you don't want to do this uh
too early right you want your key in
front of the pawn but in this case it
actually
gives us a back opposition right now
it's black's turn to move and our king
is the one forcing you away
if you run to this side then the pawn is
promoting and it's defended
and if you run in front of the pawn the
more reasonable option
then we can actually just push the pawn
yet again
our king and pawns defend every square
except for one
the king has to move out of the way
and now what do we play here
uh not pawnee eight because if we if we
promote right now it's not defended the
king will just take it
so what do we have to do first
yes so first thing we gotta again make
the red carpet we gotta defend the
promotion squares
so that's really our key here
when we have the king in the pawn we
want to whatever we're doing we want to
make sure that
we're able to get our king to defend
these
very critical promotion squares
and to do that we can either if it's our
move we can take opposition force you
out of the way
and then control the squares
and if it's black to move here
then it doesn't matter what they do if
they move away then we just take the
squares
and if they stop our king from advancing
we actually have time to push the pawn
and the king has to run away
we can jump in and defend the square and
the pawn will promote by force
but let's back up
because the point of this is to look at
known positions
and in this case
uh this is the position that we know now
we know that if we get our king to the
sixth rank uh or if you're black if you
get it to the third right but if the
king is on this rank and the pawn is one
behind it
so in this case like this
if we were black it would be the king
would be somewhere on the third rank and
the pawn would be somewhere on the
fourth rank
if we can do that
then it's a guaranteed win we know that
so if we can calculate to this position
we know we can win
let's start
at the very beginning here so this time
we have black with a pawn at the edge of
the board
what would be your recommendation to win
this game what should we try and do here
black to move
ideas
what should black do to try and win this
game either you can say moves or just
general principles
yes so like we just mentioned uh the
king needs to be in front of the pawn in
order to essentially guide it right
we're trying to form this nice red
carpet
all the way down for our pawn to just
help it march on to promotion
and to do that we need the king in front
of the pawn here's what happens if we
don't
so let's say black plays one of the
worst moves in this position e5
it looks like a very natural move
trying to get our pawn closer and closer
but without our king in front to guide
it this is actually going to allow our
opponent to get a draw and here's how so
the kings are going to you know walk
towards the pawns we can't push it again
because then we're not going to be able
to defend it
so hopefully you would at least know to
you got to bring your king in so we can
defend this pawn
and now all white needs to do is keep
our king from advancing to in front of
the pawn
so if we're going to go this way then
now it doesn't really matter um you can
go here or here
uh probably a slightly more precise move
would be to go one back so that when we
approach
you can take opposition right again this
idea that we're cutting off the king
from approaching
from every angle so the king now has to
you either have to push the pawn or back
up
and if we try and back up and try maybe
like moving in a triangle to you know
waste a move it's not going to help the
king's just going to walk back in front
and even if we take out position it
doesn't matter
because there's still no way for us to
get in front of the pawn
because when we take opposition their
king is forced to move to the side now
obviously they're going to move towards
the pawn not away from it
but now the option we have open is to
move this way but if we do that we're
still going to lose our pawn
right this is too slow it looks nice
we're trying to get in front of the pawn
but the king just walks here because
it's not guarded anymore and there's no
way to save this pawn the game is a draw
so this isn't going to work
so again regardless as long as they keep
our king even with or behind the pawn
white can hold a draw here
so let's see what happens when we get
all the way to the end because we can't
advance this pawn
let's say e4
we keep pushing up the king is going to
block us again
we can play e3
the king is blocking us and we can
slowly move our way to the end of the
board
but in this position it's actually
really important king e1 is the most
important move at this position
because if they play king to uh f1 or d1
now opposition matters because uh black
or sorry white is stuck now at the edge
of the board
taking opposition now
actually just transposes to that known
position we were looking at before
whichever way they move we can push the
pawn
and we get the same red carpet effect so
in order to prevent that
king e1 here now is the most precise
move because whichever way we go
they will stop us once again from moving
forwards so if king to d3 for instance
then king to d1 taking opposition
and we can either back off
uh or push forward the pawn if we back
off and try and reset the situation
white will just stay in front of the
pawn and then move back
directly backwards preparing to take
opposition again right again preparing
to meet us and stop our king from
advancing forward
and this is just going to be a draw
so what happens if we go back a few
moves
and ultimately we have to push this pawn
forward right the only thing that we can
try
and you can hope and pray that your
opponent just gets really confused and
moves their king over to c1 that would
be a lovely turn of events but no uh
king to e1 is the move
and this is a zugswang which is a
slightly more advanced term i believe
it's german but it's a tactic or an idea
in chess where
whatever move we play were worse
this is one of the situations in chess
where
if black could pass that would be the
best move because if we could pass and
white has to move
then white's going to have to step out
of the way of the pawn and we can defend
it because we have to move
every move we play is bad right we can't
move with the pawn and all of these king
moves
except for one
just sacrifice the pawn right if we just
move away you would just take the pawn
this is a draw
the only move that we can play to defend
the pawn
ends the game in a stalemate
our king and our pawn control every
possible square black's king could move
to uh sorry white's king so white has no
legal moves
which means the game is a draw because
it's no legal moves but not check
so that's what happens if our king is
behind the pawn and let's just really
quickly run through that again
white is going to keep their king
stopping us uh
whatever they need to do they're just
going to keep
blockading our king we're never going to
be able to approach
and when we get to the very edge of the
board they're going to play this really
important move king to e1
preparing to take opposition right
whatever way we go they're going to meet
us
and if we don't move up right if we
don't actually take opposition then they
can just bounce back and stop our pawn
from moving forward
we can reset but yeah no matter what is
played whichever way we go
the king will stop us
we can shuffle around if we'd like to
but it won't make a difference
eventually we will have to push the pawn
forward
and the king steps in front if we
defend our pawn in a stalemate if we run
away the pawn hangs
either way the game is a draw
so
that is another known position we can
add to our repertoire
right any position like this where we
know that one side can keep the king
behind the pawn that's trying to promote
that's going to be a draw
but now let's take a look at how to
actually promote the pawn
so in this case it's going to be
slightly different
we're going to move our king in front of
the pawn first
if they take opposition or not here's
what's really important if you can you
want to leave at least one space between
your king and your pawn and the reason
is
if you take opposition then your
opponent has to back off you can keep
moving forward but if your opponent
takes opposition
then we need a waiting move because if
we keep bouncing back and forth they can
follow us forever
and we can never make forward progress
in the position
so the waiting move we play here
is pawn up
and now we've taken opposition because
white has to move they have to move one
way or another and we can advance
and infiltrate the position the other
direction
so here if king to d3 for instance it
allows king to b4
and we are slowly building this red
carpet
and i'm using red intentionally just
because it's nice but it's also the nice
kind of visual image you know you this
pawn is maybe doesn't look like much now
but if it gets to the edge of the runway
it's going to be beautiful so we got to
support it there
okay
king to c2 again if they let us take
opposition we want to take it
and we keep advancing
if they don't
then we can uh you know push the pawn
but here's the nice thing is once we get
our king to the fifth
or the third or sorry the sixth of the
third we already know if we get our pawn
here now it doesn't matter whose move it
is we're gonna win
and white can't stop us from getting our
pawn here so white so black should win
this game
so black to move uh let's ask what
should black play here to win this game
e6
what was that sorry
uh
c6 you mean yeah
sure king to c6 okay we'll force our
opponent's king out of the way um
king d1
on okay i'll come back take opposition
okay so now you're forcing me out of
opposition
yes
right now that the pawn is here on the
six or sorry on the fourth i am ready to
bring the king forward form the red
carpet
and all of the promotion squares are
defended so the king again whatever
white plays here we are going to promote
to a queen
or a rook or whatever you want but
probably a queen or a rook
okay so does anyone have any questions
about that because this is again the
idea here is we want to establish this
as a known position in our repertoire
that you know if you get into a position
where you're like okay uh it could be
anything your king could be way over
here
i'm just gonna shuffle a few times
but in this position
say it's uh
black to move say there's been some
trades we got to the crazy end of a game
and now all i need to do is figure out
can i win with this one extra pawn
um i need to see okay can i get my king
in front of my pawn
if the answer is yes
then black can win
in this case it looks like i'm going to
be able to do that
white is not going to be able to stop me
from getting in front of the pawn here
and black is winning so if you know the
technique
um then you should be good right king's
gonna have to step out of the way if
they step to the side we infiltrate
whichever way they go
if they step back we can just chase them
backwards right
there's no problem here i have a
question yes
what would prevent
the dancing the palm tree squares and
enforcing the check
uh in uh where
like here or so again the danger is you
won't really want to keep your king in
front of the pawn it might not always
force a draw but any time our king is
even with the pawn there's a chance if
they can get their king in front so here
uh let's actually go back here
so yeah let's say here we can move our
pawn up to call check
now
white's king is gonna step in front and
we cannot get in front of the pawn
um if we try and run off to the side and
go around they're just going to approach
it
and our pawn is going to fall
so we're going to have to do something
else if we just want to wait move to the
side
they're going to attack our pawn and
we're behind it now trying to defend
if we push the pawn we're def behind it
and we've already seen that either way
if we end up behind the pawn
then we can't win
if they know what they're doing at least
um
so
yeah so you really want to be careful of
that
and always make sure you're if you can
just keep your king from the pawn just
as a safety precaution so like yeah here
i would say i might just push the pawn
up one um
just so i know i still have a little bit
of space and there's no threats of them
taking opposition here
and wherever they go i can either take
out position or i can you know keep
pressing forwards
a question from the chat
in the low time situation what would you
play
to try and confuse a lower rated player
into a blunder
uh if you're
talking specifically about like these
king and pawn end games if i'm looking
for to induce a blunder then i'm
probably the player with white um
because
i can't win i can only draw if they give
up this pawn so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to try and get my key as close
as i can i'm going to try and keep you
know putting tension on the position
taking opposition as much as i can
and you know just hoping they don't know
what to do
um and i'm gonna just make it as hard as
possible for them
um
and any time that i can you know try and
trick them into
blocking their pawn anytime i can trick
them into you know not making the best
move
that's probably what you just have to do
but the best way to do it is just know
the position really really well
understand what makes one side win what
makes one side lose and in this case i
know that
black needs to keep their king in front
of the pawn if i can at any point trick
them into playing you know one wrong
move
like
say we're somewhere in this position and
my opponent is just you know trying to
advance the pawn
yeah this is pretty pretty easy to do
right and now
this is uh a draw
it doesn't look like it but the king is
in front of the pawn but there's no
waiting move i've taken opposition and
now you're gonna have to shuffle to the
side forever
or you're gonna have to move backwards
and now i've stopped you
so
just you know knowing the position well
is gonna help you do that
okay any other questions about promoting
with the king and the pawn against a
king
okay one other thing to note
in promotion is
there's a big difference if the pawn is
a rook pawn so by rook pawn we mean one
of the pawns that starts on the file
where the rooks start you know so these
two edges of the board
if it's a rook pawn then with best play
it's a draw either way
now if you're playing with white you
want to try and you know again maybe
confuse your opponent into not knowing
what to do and trying to promote but if
you're black there's a really simple
thing you can do here that's going to
help you win the game
so
if
anyone had the black pieces here what
would you play just you know really make
a very easy draw and not let your
opponent have a win
there's a very you know foolproof way to
to get into yourself at least to draw in
this position
i know where you're supposed to end up
but i don't know
uh where are you supposed to end up in
the corner yeah so
the amazing thing here is you don't have
to worry about the king being front of
the pawn you have to worry about slowing
the pawn down taking opposition all you
have to do is get your king to this
corner
and bounce
back and forth
so in this position i'm just going to
move to the corner
and i'm just going to shuffle for the
rest of the game i'm going to play king
to b8 king to a8 king to b8 until my
opponent doesn't let me play one of
those moves
because your king will never be able to
approach and take this square you know
you'll never be able to defend the
promotion square
and at some point
you know you can play as many waiting
moves as you want to but eventually
it doesn't really make a difference
i can even not take the pawn it's i
don't have to because at some point you
are going to have to push this pawn
check and i'm going to run in the corner
and it's the same thing as before you
either defend the pawn and it's a
stalemate
uh or
you move the king away and i take it um
you can sam jam bounce back and forth on
a different rank the difference is you
can be forced away from that rank so
like i could try and bounce back and
forth here
but eventually white can you know force
me off of this rank
because now i have to step backwards
so it doesn't really make a difference
because it's the result's gonna be the
same anyway but just without having to
worry or think about it if you just go
to the corner
you're at the edge of the board there's
nothing they can do to force you out so
if they push the pawn it's just going to
be a drop and if they don't
then they're not promoting and it's
going to be a draw either way
so just a little uh
amendment i wanted to add to that
okay
again something to help us you know in
end games like i talked about
calculations are really really
uh important because one move can make
the difference between winning and
losing
so in this case uh it is so like to move
it is white to move
i want you to
tell me do you think that white can
promote or that black can catch the pawn
before promotion so is this game a win
for white or will this game be a draw
what do you think
and yes uh mma matrix only the flank
pawn that works anything else you want
to stop their king from being in front
of the pawn
or you want to keep your king in front
of the pawn as much as it can but with a
flank pawns it doesn't matter
okay uh yeah white to move in this
position
can the pawn promote or will the black
king stop it
what do we think
so
king will stop it okay
i don't think so
i think the king
king can't stop it okay
if white move you can promote
um
looks like white's on time might win so
we have some different thoughts
uh here's the way to do it right you can
calculate and you can think okay pawn
moves king moves pawn moves king moves
pawn moves king moves but it's very easy
when you're playing over the board you
know you don't have this nice arrow
function
to lose track of squares or forget which
piece is where
and you it just takes some more time you
have to really think it through
a very easy tip
uh is called like this the box method
and for those who don't know it it's a
super super clear-cut way to figure out
uh which side
will win in this type of situation
so what you do is you figure out when
it's uh the king's turn to move so right
now it's white's turn to move
where is our pawn gonna be
when it's uh black's turn to move and
the answer to that is on h4
the pawn will move two spaces
right so this is one trick you want to
be careful if the pawn is starting on
the second or seventh rank because it
can move those two spaces and that can
make all the difference so the pawn will
be on h4
so now we create an imaginary box right
where we start on this square
and we create the box in a diagonal to
the edge of the board
now this is just a line but to make it a
box you then you know just connect
all the points
so this is our box right the pawn will
be on h4 when it is our opponent
starting to move
we make a diagonal from where the pawn
will be to the edge of the board
and this is our box
and the way we solve this is if black's
king can step into the box on their turn
so that includes all of these squares if
they can step into any square in the box
then black will catch the pawn if not
they will miss it in this case we can
also see by how many moves right black
is one square away from the box
so they're going to be one score away
from stopping the pawn
black is one square too slow the pawn
promotes and this works every time um
it is a really really useful tool
instead of having to you know sit and
count all of those moves out so here's
another example
all right uh so it's black's turn to
move
can white catch the pawn or not
and the pawn is moving uh this way
what do we think will the
white can catch the pawn yep
let's take a look
pawn will come to g5
so this is our box
and it looks like white indeed can enter
the box
because it can only just enter the box
and it's not already in there it's going
to catch it on the very last move
pawn up
king moves
up king moves on up king moves pawn up
and we catch it just in time
so this is useful uh for a lot of
reasons again it can help you just
calculate some really complicated
positions here's a way we can start to
maybe apply this so in this example it
is uh white's turn to move and as we can
see we have two pawns
to black's one pawn
but black's king is closer
so if we had our king closer we could
brute force our way through trade pawns
and promote and you couldn't stop us
black's king is closer which means the
question is
can we force one of our pawns to promote
before black can catch us
what do we think
can black draw this game or can white
force a win here
and remember you can use the tool of the
box if you know what square the pawn is
going to be on when it's black's turn to
move
but we do have to think of every option
black has
and let me give you one example that
doesn't work
if we try and move our king in
this isn't going to work right black can
black's king beats us in the race
and
anything we try to do now it's too late
the king will stop us
so
black or sorry white to move
what do we do so we have some people say
white wins some people say draw
some people say play h5 and then play g5
what do we think
give you another minute or so to take a
look at this one
can white force a win or can black force
a draw
so we have black and forced to draw
does anyone in here think white can
force a win
okay so either everyone's unsure or
black and forced to draw well let's take
a look and see what actually can happen
so
uh someone in the chat actually oh sorry
someone say something so i feel like
white can win okay how do you think
white's gonna win
what should they try and do
right moving the king doesn't work so
which of these pawns do you move or does
it matter you would move the
outer
the inside the one closest to the king
okay we're going to move our g pawn
real quick someone in the chat suggested
moving this pawn first i actually think
um
this move doesn't really make a lot of
intuitive sense uh i think they're
thinking you know when we push this one
this is one space closer but the problem
is still their king is i think too close
because now we can start to think about
the box
um
i'm gonna move my king in
if i push this pawn up
black does not have to take
if i take i think you're right
if i take now my pawn runs
um and my pawn is gonna be outside of
the box of this king but if i don't take
uh
and this pawn slips past
my king's gonna catch it but i got one
more thing i gotta think about what if
i take this pawn with this pawn
okay my king's to me outside the box
again so it looks like oh maybe black is
gonna you know be able to
uh maybe white can win here but there's
a really interesting thing to consider
this pawn is also running
like it's a queen
and this pawn is here but it looks like
the queen can stop promotion so does h5
work
that's a really good question
oops
h5
king over
g5 king e5
pawn takes king f6
king is in the box
so with precise play we can realize the
king is going to be in this box
so h5 is not quite good enough
let's take a look at g5
so g5 seems to be the move that makes
the most sense uh we're threatening
quite a few things here
what are blacks options here what should
uh black play right
what do you think is the best move for
black
especially those who think black can
hold a draw here what should black do
well
yeah take the pawn seems like the only
reasonable option
anything else is not going to work and
we can again use the box to figure that
out if h5 just trying to blockade
this pawn is going to be
the king is outside of the box so this
pawn will promote and this one will be
stuck
with this one so white wins
and if the king tries to move in
what about then
it's not going to catch up let's take a
look
pawn goes up
wait a minute isn't the king inside the
box
what do you think space is regardless
so yeah wait so if
black just moves to the king is this a
draw
yeah
no
pawn can take the pawn doesn't have to
move forward that would mean then this
is the box
but the punk can also take which means
this is the box and the king cannot get
into that
so king moving is also too slow
so black has to take
only reasonable move
what should white play here
so we have two options to consider
how do we calculate this out if we we
have to think about both boxes right if
we take this pawn
the box
is here the king enters the box if we
take
this is a draw
black's king is just barely close enough
to catch us
so what if we don't take what if we push
what happens here
we push the king is outside of the box
but now
again we have to think
black also has a pawn
and our king is also outside of that box
so now
it's a race of the pawns
pawn
pawn
up up promotes
promote
both sides have a queen at the same turn
this game
is a draw
white cannot force a win in this
position remarkably despite having these
two pawns because the king is just
barely too close the king is able to
fight off the box the only way we can
try and you know circumvent that problem
is by pushing past and then black's king
is truly outside of the box
but so is our king
both sides will get a queen
oops
so yes
it's possible to win if they both
promote in one of them
right oh absolutely yeah if somebody
blunders then yes 100
uh
either player could win this game um but
with best play it's a draw um
there's no way for one player to like
force the other player into checkmate um
if it was black's turn to move it'd be
interesting because black light's king
is very near the edge of the board there
might be a way to try and force some
kind of checkmate i don't think there
would be but regardless with its whites
starting to move black skin is too much
in the center and anywhere you try and
go to check and force the king away
eventually the queen will be able to
intercept
so with best play this will be a draw
but that doesn't mean you shouldn't
still play on from this position right
especially against some lower rated
opponents
okay
uh let's move
to another example here
this time i want to look at something
slightly easier if you have two
connected past pawns
there's a really simple trick to know
that's going to help you win without
really thinking about it if you do all
the same things you did with the king in
one pawn you're going to be fine if you
get your king in front of the pawn
and keep your king in front of the pawn
and slowly you know make the red carpet
and guide your coupons down
you can absolutely win that way it will
take a little more time a little more
calculation a little more thinking
especially to make sure you're not
creating any stalemate threats or
anything like that
so
um the very easy technique i would
recommend here
is very simple
you can start by just pushing the pawns
and you can let white get as close as he
wants
and now
white has a problem
because
you can now bring your king in and start
working to keep moving these pawns
forward
and even though this pawn is not
defended white cannot take it
because again let's think about the box
if white takes this pawn
this is our box and white's king on d5
will be too far away to get into this
box
the pawn will run and white cannot catch
him
so because of that you just very simply
keep moving your king forward
and keep pushing these pawns as long as
one of them is defended uh and you can
either get your king in front or not it
doesn't really make a difference but
we're just gonna slowly shuffle our king
and move him forward until we can push
another pawn forward
and then you can make this position
again
we can just shuffle our king
even if we aren't defending this pawn it
doesn't matter
the only reason we're moving our king to
the side and not backwards is because we
do want to keep defending these squares
and eventually we're just going to get
to this kind of end game so now you have
to be careful not to stalemate here
uh
what should black play to win this game
and not
blunder a draw here black to move how
can we win
we've gotten both pawns here to the
third rank
uh sebes i don't know how to say your
name in the chat but says king c2 i
think you mean king c3 probably but
bring the king closer um okay this makes
sense to me
and now
white wants to stop you from defending a
promotion square so let's say king here
to d1
now our king can't come closer
what should we do here
uh pawn to d2 okay
uh king only has one move
king e2
um
yeah king c2 now and we are defending
upon it doesn't matter that they can
take this one once again because we are
promoting
um so the important thing though is to
not fall into kind of a stalemate idea
so back in this line you could also just
push the pawn forward you can bring the
king in
i would push upon first and do the same
thing
and just here's where we have to be a
little careful right
um we're gonna do the same thing as
before
if you end up in this type of position
the key is just do not play something
like king to d3 which will you know
happily stalemate your opponent for them
not so happily for you
but no you just keep moving around and
forcing the king out and eventually
whether we do it you know this way or
this way
the king has to move we can defend the
promotion square and happily get a queen
so someone wants to play just pawn to e2
for spice i guess you can
i think you're looking at
uh like this position
like here maybe
i don't know exactly we're saying but
yeah you can be spicy if you want but as
long as you defend the promotion square
that's the most important thing
all right here's another one
this one's a little more complicated
so white to move in this position
what would you play here we have two
connected past pawns or sorry two
connected pawns versus one pawn from
black
uh and there we do need to be a little
bit precise
sorry
check so uh d5 check
okay so that's one recommendation
uh king e4 recommended in the chat
any other moves or anyone agree with one
of those two moves
it's white to move yeah how can we try
to win this game
wait i'll tell you white can win this
game
um so the way to do it d5 has been
suggested king to e4 suggested
sorry yeah it doesn't matter because
like either pawn
could defend
so here's what's interesting is i will
tell you it actually does matter a great
deal and both of these moves
draw the game
with best play black and win and we can
figure that out by thinking of our known
positions what's going to happen in
either case
is
our king is going to be stuck behind the
pawn um because black has the second
pawn black has a really beautiful way to
win let's say king to e4 for instance
if king to e4
d5 check
and they're either taking this pawn and
running
or we take them
king to d6
we cannot continue to defend this pawn
so we have to move our king away
it doesn't matter where you go black
takes and now look what happened we have
a king in one pawn and our king is
behind the pawn
black forces a draw
if d5 first check
i actually don't remember this line
exactly but d5
the king
can't just move backwards
and the problem is they're going to keep
us away
they're going to keep our king behind
the pawns
and at whatever point we try and break
through with c5 they will trade and our
king will be behind our pawn so
something like this for instance
the king can just kind of move back but
whatever point we try to trade
they'll be ready to take opposition and
again this is a known position we know
this is a draw
with best play our king is stuck behind
the pawn and we have not reached the
sixth rank yet
black is
uh surviving
but it's funny because king e4 looks uh
to me this is probably what i would play
if i didn't know this position it looks
like such a natural move
um
so you have to be really really careful
to you know calculate what can my
opponent do king to e4
pawn amazingly pushed d5 check this is
forcing a trade
and then the king can sit here on d6
and my king will be stuck behind my pawn
if we know that a king behind a pawn
will force a draw
then you have to be careful of this so
what's a way we can win this
avoiding that kind of trap
well we looked at check check doesn't
work remember because after d5 uh the
king's going to back off and
our king is going to be behind the pawn
they're going to force our
way
so we need to get our king in front of
the pawns if we don't do that we won't
be able to win
so c5 doesn't work because if we play c5
they'll take our pawn
we take theirs and king takes
so yeah well let me ask you so if we
play here
they take
what are you gonna do
if you don't take then whatever you do
they're going to take you next move if i
go here they're just going to take me
so
yeah we can't trade our pawns here
so the way to win this is yes someone is
suggesting king to c3 which i believe
you can win but it'll maybe be a little
harder i would go king to e3 and my idea
is i need to avoid this this is what
we're going to call a landmine square if
i step on the square then i've blown up
right because they're going to push
forward and we know that's going to be a
draw
so king to e3 i think king c3 probably
works it'll just take a little longer
but king e3 and my idea is i'm going to
walk around this dangerous square
and try and force my king in front of
the palm this way
so let's say
uh black to move now at any point they
can't ever play d5 unless i'm on this
square if black tries to play d5 now
what will i do
why it's a move
c5 importantly not taking the pawn
if we trade then again their king is
going to end up in front and our king
cannot support the pawn so we push past
the c5
and we're going to be able to slowly
bring our king in
and help the pawn promote because this
pawn is going to be too weak and it's
going to fall
so they can't ever push
d5
so instead the king's going to have to
run around and try and stop us you know
we're going to keep moving forward still
avoiding that landmine square of e4
because again even here it's going to be
the same thing
right we always have to be very careful
of that
so we're going to keep moving around
and black is going to try and stop us at
every turn
so black is now
stopping our king from moving forward we
have to keep routing around here to the
side
whenever we can
we're gonna take opposition
because that's gonna force our opponent
to make a choice you either run away
from the pawn and we take it
or you move back to defend it and i keep
encroaching right my king keeps moving
forward
if you take opposition again my pawns
are stopping black's king from advancing
so i can keep
running around to the side i believe
this will also work
here
but
i think the computer gives this nice
move d5
with the idea that my king is going to
get in front of your pawn first
you can't run over here right you have
to stay and keep stopping my king
because if you run forward
you get one of my pawns if you want
but i'm going to get this one eventually
and my king is in front
so your king can't do that
instead you have to back off
and white's just going to keep you know
slowly taking opposition keep pushing
you away
wherever black goes we can still take
opposition
eventually this pawn is falling it's
very slowly
methodically moving in
and every time you take opposition
you're you're forcing the opponent to
concede space
and here again we have a king and two
pawns a very very easy win for
white
so again coming back to this the
importance of this lesson is really the
landmine square
um you want to be really careful and
think about what moves your opponent can
play that are going to mess you up
and the nice thing is we don't have to
calculate to the end of a game right
with our idea of known positions if i
can calculate okay my king is going to
step onto e4
wanting to defend my pawns
if my opponent calls check it seems bad
because i will take it
but then their king steps in front and
now my king can't defend the spot
anymore right it's on this square my
pawn is blocking me here and their king
is covering this square
so i have to back off i'm going to lose
a pawn and my king's going to be behind
the pawn
so being able to calculate just that far
in advance right it's still a decent
amount of calculation right end games
are tough
but
being able to calculate to this position
is much much easier than trying to
calculate the whole rest of the game
because once you reach here you can stop
calculating you say okay i know that's a
draw i can't win that game let's just
try and find a different variation
okay
a couple more examples here
in this case white is up a past pawn
right we have these
two pawns to the side both connected for
white and black but white has this one
extra pawn over here on b4
um
and black's king is going to you know
try and keep us from advancing notice
that our king is behind the pawn
or sorry equal with it so it's not a
head
um
so the question is can white win this
position or
with best play can black force a draw
what do we think
easy win for white someone says in the
chat
white win
no one to make pawn moves seems like a
draw
so we have some back and forth thoughts
let's take a look at this position
uh and actually yeah blarum has the
right idea here
so because we're these pawns are all
locked up and our king is behind the
pawns some people might think well this
is going to be a draw because i can't do
anything with these puns over here
and black's king is going to keep me
behind my pawn forever the game is a
draw
however
when there's more pawns on the board
than just this one
we can actually change our plan slightly
because now
our plan doesn't have to be how do i
promote this pawn our plan can be
how do i get my king over to these pawns
the way to do that
is to force your king back
with this one
and then sacrifice it and run over and
pick up these other ones
so
a very simple way to do that is we can
just you know push this pawn forward
we're going to keep taking space black
is going to do their best to stop our
king from moving forward but we can push
our pawn because the point isn't that
we're trying to you know keep the pawn
safe and
defended and promoted we know we can't
do that
black can keep stopping us
but eventually we can abandon it i might
even go one move farther
but it doesn't really make a difference
because at some point we can say our
king is going to be closer and i'm going
to be able to pick up these pawns
and you have to stop me from both taking
these pawns to promotion and this one
and you can't pick both
if you try and go the other way
and stop me over here
you can't stop this one from promoting
so black has to fall back and stop this
pawn here
and by the time they've taken it it is
too late
we have gobbled up these other two pawns
so if you push a check on
b7 there then you can force it
uh where
no no no uh if you push on b7 you don't
force a draw
if you're willing to abandon this pawn
um this the lesson is the same right you
need to run away and see that i can take
these pawns first if i try and defend it
then yeah this is a draw this is a
stalemate because no pawns can move
and black's king is fully trapped in
this corner but if you're willing to let
go of this pawn
and say the point is this pawn i'm using
is kind of a sacrificial lamb
and i'm going to be able to get to these
faster
than black's king my king will be in
front and i have two beautiful pawns
then uh white is going to be winning
and i want to show a very similar theme
with this next one
so
in this game uh both sides
have two pawns white has two connected
pawns black has two separated pawns but
one of them is a past pawn with nothing
in front of it and black's king is
behind the pawn
first impressions of this position what
do we think
is one side winning is one side drawing
i believe it's uh black to move here
no i'm sorry it's white to move here
what do we think of this position
if you're not sure that's fine but feel
free to take a guess
seems like a draw
it is uh white to move
seems like a draw
force the black g-pawn to make a choice
different thoughts here i'll tell you
stockfish says this is a draw and i
believe stockfish
but this was actually a grand master
game uh i want to see if i wrote down
who played it
i did not i'll look that up and maybe
put it in the comments later but um
it was a master level game maybe not a
grand master
but in this game it was white to move
and white actually played a losing move
white played the move g4
which actually loses in this position
black now goes from having a draw to
being able to force a win
so does anyone take a shot and trying to
figure out what black did here to win
this game
again end games are tough one wrong move
can be the difference between winning
and losing
what would you play if you had the black
pieces
uh this one
yeah this is it um and this is actually
very similar to the last position that
we just looked at
uh the difference is black just it
doesn't have this extra pawn here right
in the last position
it was two and two
and one extra pawn but in this position
uh black doesn't need this extra pawn
and here's why is because we can look
and see if white ever tries to push this
pawn what's gonna happen
we take
and now we have a race again
um so we have to calculate that out
push
push push
push
push
we get a queen
and they don't
oh i'm sorry they do get a queen but the
difference is
it's the box again i'm sorry
is here
black's king is in this box
white's king
is not in this box
so we can abandon
our pawn on b5
run over and stop this one
and white cannot get to this point in
time doesn't matter if you take it or
not
white is too far outside of the box
so black is winning
if you ever try and push
so instead
in the game king to b3 was played
king to d5
and again black realizes i don't need
this pawn it's the same thing as last
time this is the sacrificial lamb my
pawn is going to get here first
now in this position it's black to move
you have to be very careful
what move should black play here
in order to still win this game because
you can go very very wrong here
uh
uh that's what white would play it for
it's black to move
okay king f4 suggested
oh you're good
any other thoughts
what would you play black to move
king e5 yes okay
someone said uh
someone something else
uh f4 okay
yeah i think e5 probably is okay um
but there's uh i think both of these
moves do the same thing f4 is the best
move
and the reason is if we go to f3 which
looks like the very natural response
what is white going to play
yeah we always always need to keep an
eye on the box
so in this position
white can push their pawn now
and our pawn is going to be out of the
box
or sorry yeah
here then push
and there's no way to stop it because
either you take our pawn and this one
runs
or you don't take our pawn and it either
takes you or runs forward
um
if for instance uh
if pawn takes then you cannot stop
this pawn from running and they're both
going to become queens
and if you take uh our pawn here on g4
then we take your pawn
and there are no pawns left
so you have to be very careful you
always want to stay in the box
so king to f4 here
yeah king takes g4 does not work because
i'll just take and there's no pawns left
so king to f4
king f3 is a draw
after h4 there's no good move for black
so king to f4 staying in the box staying
ready to defend and now this idea
doesn't work because
my king catches you
so king to c4
what else came to d3
and white tries to get in front and take
opposition and they are so close but
they are one move too slow
black's king stays ahead of the pawn and
we have seen this position before
how does black win in this position
how does black win what do we do
just promote the pawn
because we're reaching this rank without
check we are cutting off these squares
and the king has to move out of the way
we come defend the promotion square and
the game is
over
so that is all the time we have tonight
but thank you all for joining both in
person and online hope you learned
something about the endgames
again it's very tricky so feel free to
keep studying at your own pace and i
hope to see you again next week take
care everyone
[Applause]